Joining me now,
the former
Manhattan D.A.,
the district attorney, Cyrus Vance.
He initially opened
this investigation into Trump
but did not bring charges.
SOUCIE There's so much to ask you about
because, you know,
I know you don't want
to be a central figure in this,
but of course you are.
And what you did and didn't do
and why is is so important here.
So when we go through
the actual indictment, 34
counts, every one of them
a felony
related to falsifying business records.
Right. It's one after the other.
All that changes really is the date.
Is there anything in this indictment
as you go through it
that you did not expect to see?
Erin, first of all,
thank you for having me on
and it's good to see you.
I think the indictment
in one sense was as predicted,
it was a indictment containing counts
around felony counts, around false
business records
elevated by the object
of the misdemeanor crimes
to affect the voting laws,
either state or federal.
What I did find different
and where I differ
from some of your excellent panelists
that were just
on, is
I found that
the document actually quite detailed.
I mean, it is a speaking indictment
and it has quite a bit of detail about
the history
and laid out the facts underlying them,
the various counts that are listed.
So I thought that the indictment
provided more detail than
than perhaps others expected.
Okay.
So then you're referring here
to the 12 page statement of facts, right.
Which accompanied
the actual charges themselves.
And in in this,
you know, I was I was referring to the
I was referring to the indictment itself.
So the indictment itself. Okay.
So so can you explain there then?
Because the description
that we've seen sort
of has been that it was barebones, right?
That it just lists the date
and that
the voucher number of the check and,
you know,
false entry of business records.
So can you explain what you did
find in here
that was more detail than you expected?
Well, I think at least the indictment
I think I read was
the counts are always fairly barebones,
but it's the prefatory
purgatory language
that is used before the counts that out
that outlines
the scheme that the prosecution
is making public
to educate the public,
presumably on the background of the facts
that relate
then to the substantive counts.
All right.
So in in that
section, as this goes through,
Alvin Bragg lays out the.
So what did you find there that was new
or that that surprised you?
These details here?
Well, I'm not really surprised.
I think it was an indictment
that was not bare bones.
I'm just saying, in contrast
to some of the comments
in your prior
panelists, I've seen bare bones
indictments before
and they can be very bare bones.
This is not a bare bones indictment.
All right.
So let me try to understand
maybe a different way if I ask this.
Alvin Bragg
said he got additional evidence
in this case
and he said that in the press conference.
So from reading the indictment
and you obviously were very familiar
with all the evidence in the case
that was available
until you left the DA's office.
So from what you read in the indictment,
are you clear on what the new evidence
that Alvin Bragg obtained was?
No, I can't
I can't, Aaron,
go through paragraph, line by line
and say what was new and
what was within our
within our knowledge.
First and foremost,
I have to be mindful of confidences
that go around the process
when we were looking at this matter.
This was in the grand jury context
and the things I simply can't relate.
But what I can say
by way of background is
we began our investigation
in roughly 2017.
At the same time,
we learned
that the federal prosecutors
in the Southern District of New York
were looking at Mr. Trump as well.
And I
was asked by the Southern District
to stand our stand, our efforts down,
because they said
they've got this in hand.
And I,
I because I believe
the Southern District
is an excellent office
with great prosecutors.
I was prepared to defer to them.
I was surprised.
Therefore, in 2018,
when Michael Cohen pled guilty,
that the Southern District
never went anywhere with that case
and it stopped.
In the meantime,
we had been focusing on
an economic crimes investigation.
And I can say that because
Mr.
Trump sued
me and the office
attaching our grand jury subpoena
in federal court.
And so we were on to a
a what I would say is a different
economic crimes investigation.
And
and we're then moving forward
on on a broader investigation.
All right.
So when Alvin Bragg was asked
the question
at a presser, at the presser,
he just was just asked,
and it said the
the question included the premise
that your predecessor declined to charge.
Now, in his answer to the question,
Bragg did not challenge that premise.
So I just want to give you a chance
to clear the record here.
You're saying you
you stood down
because the Southern District of New York
asked you to.
Is that the same thing as saying that?
I mean, did
you specifically declined
to bring charges
because you didn't think
they were merited or not at the time?
I don't think we ever
I I'm sure I'm
sure a district attorney Bragg
has has new facts
that he gathered
during his investigation.
So
really, Aaron, I think I've explained it.
There was
a federal investigation
which I deferred to.
And by the time that went nowhere,
we then had already picked up
an economic crimes investigation
which had to take place during COVID
and in furtherance
of which we had to go
to the Supreme Court twice
and get a ruling by the Supreme Court
in, I think, 2020
that the president
and the Trump Organization
had to turn over
all its financial records to us,
which ultimately
then led to an indictment
of the corporation,
of the CFO of the corporation,
which ultimately was convicted
after trial. The $1.6 million.
It was a lot of work that we did.
Yes.
Yeah,
but but
just to be clear,
you're saying
you think he got new information.
So do I read into that
that you didn't have enough
and that he must have gotten gotten more?
I would
you know,
I wouldn't read Aaron into anything
too much.
You know, we
we did a very thorough investigation.
We obviously had to work within a system
of dual prosecutions
that were being conducted
by two officers.
We ultimately spent a great deal of time
reestablishing principles of law
that the Supreme Court
reiterated in their in their decision
and went on to build
the financial crimes, invest
against the Trump Organization,
which is the alter ego of the president.
One final question to you, sir,
if I may,
and this case is,
it seems in terms
to get to a felony, right.
Is based upon
the premise
that the president
of the United States did this
because he wanted to be elected. Right.
And he suppressed this information
because he wanted to be elected.
We do know, as a matter of fact, from
not just what Michael Cohen has said,
but historical
record about even involving
some of the individuals
in this case,
where stories were given to magazines
and and been suppressed, squelched
when Trump was not a candidate.
So are you confident that this clears
the hurdle that his motive
was really to do this
so that he could get elected
when he was doing it
prior to being a candidate for election?
Well, I don't think, Erin, it's my job
to make that judgment call
from from the outside.
That was district attorney's job.
And I think he's obviously said
what he's going to do.
But if I can, I'd like to make
just two quick points
before we go stepping back.
Number one, today was a peaceful day.
The federal government,
the FBI,
the NYPD, Secret Service
and court officers
notwithstanding fears of a violence and
and extreme behavior.
It was an orderly proceeding.
And that,
I think, speaks
well of Judge Mershon
and of New York City
to be able to hand this proceeding
going forward.
I think we should all be very pleased
and grateful. Second,
outside of the legal work,
what's going on in court,
there's obviously politics
that are driving opinions
across America.
This is interestingly a little bit
like what happened with Bill Clinton,
but only with other parties
when he was investigated
by Ken Starr for five years.
Ultimately, the president,
then president,
surrendered his law license
in order to resolve the investigation.
All the Democrats were outraged
that the Republicans
were going after Bill Clinton.
All the
all the Republicans felt
that it was absolutely appropriate
to look into Bill Clinton's
sexual dalliances.
So let's put the politics.
Let's let
let's let the politics be handled
by the politicians.
And let's just make sure
that we keep our eye
on having the legal proceedings
orderly and supported by by all of us.
All right.
Well, thank you very much, Cy Vance.
I appreciate your time.
And our special coverage continues
right after this.